this is the hyacinth macaw  it's big it's bright and it's vulnerable  to lots of threats  the largest parrot by length in the  world it can grow up to 40 inches  their feathers are a beautiful striking  blue  unfortunately their good looks have made  them highly desirable in the illegal pet  trade fetching upwards of ten thousand  dollars  hyacinths are native to central and  south america  primarily in the scrub lands at the  outskirts of the rain forest  it is an affectionate bird but its  powerful beak carries over 200 pounds of  pressure per square inch strong enough  to crack a coconut their diet in the  wild consists mostly of nuts from native  palms  beyond being a hot commodity in the pet  trade hyacinths are watching their  habitat get converted to farmland  leaving them less and less space to live  this is the hyacinth macaw  you